♪ ♪ ♪
- Comment s'est formée la Lune?
En combien de temps? Et est-ce
une jumelle de la Terre
ou un astre à part entière?
que les astrophysiciens
se posent depuis longtemps.
FRÉDÉRIQUE BARON,
astrophy- La Lune, c'est notre e
naturel, elle est juste là,
le jour, la nuit. C'est
fascinant de savoir qu'en fait,
on ne sacomment elle s'est form,
même maintenant.
- L'hypothèse la plus courante :
la Terre aurait été percutée
par Théia, une protoplanète
de la taille de Mars.
Les débris de Théia se seraient
ensuite agglomérés durant
la forme qu'on connaît
de la Lune aujourd'hui.
- Maintenant, on a une nouvelle
hypothèse qui nous dirait
ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'il
y a eu une collision majeure,
très rapide, avec un bon angle
d'incidence, qui a fait
notre satellite, la Lune,
a été formé très, très,
très rapidement.
- Cette théorie d'une équipe
et britanniques est basée
sur une simulation réalisée
par un superordinateur.
Elle suggère que la collision
l'angle d'attaque et la force
gigantesque de l'impact auraient
pratiquement désintégré Théia
et complètement remodelére.re.r.
- On a en effet l'impression
de voir des objets mous
vraiment au début du système
solaire, et ce qu'on voit,
par exemple, la pr
Terre, bien, elle serait
en fusio'est très,
très chaud, bien, c'est
essentie
de la lave.
- Encore plus surp plus surp pl:
la simulation montre que la Lune
se serait ensuite formée à très
heures à peine, à partir
iel provenant
majoritairement de la Terre.
ne serait donc pas faite
à 30 % de matériel terrestre,
comme le suggère l'hypothèseutô,
ce qui correspond aux analyses
des roches rapportées
de la Lune.n-
là, la Lune se retrouve à avoir
un coeur qui appartient plutôt
à la protoplanète Mars,
recouveremble beaucoup plus
à la Terre.
- Cette Lune toute jeune
va ensuite continuer de
se transimpacts impacts impactss
qu'entraîne la formation
de notre système solaire.
Aujourd'hui, elle est froide,
lentement de nous, à raison
de trois centimètres par a
- Éventuellement, elle va
devenir de plus en plus loin,
liée gravitationnellement
à notre planète Terre...
dans fort longtemps.
- Ici Normand Grondin,  Radio-Co